[Music]
one of the great things that I love
about what I do is we get to take on
some of the biggest challenges in global
health and global development and one of
those challenges is water sanitation and
hygiene everybody needs clean water and
you know to quote the book everybody
poops and dealing with this in a clean
and sanitary way is really important for
quality of life and it's also really
important for health and getting rid of
certain diseases one of the biggest
challenges over the last couple years a
really fun technological challenges has
been to reinvent the toilet project the
basic theme of this was looking at are
there new solutions 21st century
solutions to sanitation echoing what we
saw in telephone and communication
systems where a lot of countries
completely skipped over building a big
network of landlines and traditional
phones and went straight to cell phones
the question was could we come up with
the equivalent technology that would
jump over building out sewer networks in
giant water expensive water treatment
plants and jump immediately to
non-network sanitation and it turns out
that new approaches are possible using
mechanical engineering and chemical
engineering approaches there's actually
a lot of free energy in the waste that
can be used to process itself if the
machine to do it is design correctly and
you can actually do this in a fairly
cost-effective way so the reinvent the
toilet challenge was kicked off about
five years ago in order to get
universities different companies design
firms and so on to actually think about
this and put a 21st century innovation
applied to the problem of human
sanitation and it's been remarkably cool
and successful so far to see the
different approaches that have come up
there was one team of a lot of Hertz
fellows that started working on figuring
out new ways to do use pyrolysis and
other approaches for using electro
for drying and combusting one group is
running a steam engine off of human
waste as an input stream and where a
community would used to have ten tons of
waste the day now of a sudden it runs a
steam engine that generates 150
kilowatts of electricity and puts out
10,000 to 20,000 litres a day of potable
water so this is just really exciting to
see what innovation can do what new
technologies can do and actually taking
on some of these really big challenges
and saying what would be a really
definitive technological solution to
this that actually solves the problem in
a way that we would never have imagined
trying 25 or 30 years ago